capitaine
rapport de la situation
14 victimes en tout
40 et demi morts
et le classeur ils l'ont pris
un dossier des renseignements il
contient les noms et les localisations
de centaines d'agents vietnamiens il
faut le récupérer et le nettoyer coûte
que coûte je vais vous envoyer quelqu'un
qui peut s'occuper de ça
il me faut trois équipes nous combattons
à un nouvel ennemi ne vient pas du ciel
il ne vient pas par la mer
il emprunte des tunnels
Ackerman c'est votre équipe qui
descendra vous êtes ingénieur et vous
êtes intelligent je compte sur vos dons
d'observation et d'analyses la priorité
est de récupérer ou de détruire ces
documents confidentiels qu'il est pas là
laissez tomber et comment vous savez
parce que il n'aurait pas laissé sans
surveillance
[Musique]
on va devoir faire froid j'ai pas envie
de vous perdre tout le reste on s'en
fout bien
t'es pas spécialement peut-être les
combats mais on se bat avec des
ingénieurs ici
une victoire se mesure en nombre de
cadavres
comment les compter s'ils sont sous
terre
un par un
[Musique]
c'est juste une guerre